Write the following
numbers as complex numbers.
And just as a little
bit of a review,
a complex number
is a number that
has a real part or
an imaginary part.
Let me make that
clear-- has a real part
and an imaginary part.
I'm going to write some
variables here-- a plus bi,
where a is real and b is real.
This is a complex number.
This part right over
here is the real part.
That is the real
part of the number.
And this part right
over here is imaginary.
And why is it imaginary?
Because it is a
scaled-up version
of this special number,
the imaginary unit.
It's the special number i.
It's scaled up by
b in this case.
And you may or may not
already be familiar.
I know it's kind
of a wacky thing.
But the definition of
i says that i squared
is equal to negative 1.
Hey, we didn't have any
numbers before where
if we took the square,
we get negative 1.
Now if you take i squared,
you get negative 1.
So what's neat about
imaginary numbers
is that their
squares are negative.
And what's useful
about them is it
allows us to solve
a bunch of equations
that we couldn't have
solved if you're only
looking for real solutions.
That has all sorts of
implications in engineering,
especially, and other things
like physics and all the rest.
So right now, you
just really have
to go with this definition.
You just have to go with
this definition and this one.
And as we do more
numbers, and especially
once you see a lot more
engineering applications,
hopefully you'll
realize the value of i
or the value of
imaginary numbers.
So going back to the problem--
write the following numbers
as complex.
So this number right
here, this is just
a plain, vanilla negative 21.
It just looks like
a real number to me.
Well, how do I write
it as a complex number?
Well, I write it
as a combination
of a real and an
imaginary number.
So I could just write
this as negative 21--
that's the real
part-- plus 0 times i.
0 times i is 0, so it's still
just going to be negative 21.
We have no imaginary
part, really.
So this is just the
complex version of it--
very straightforward.
Same thing down here.
7i is an imaginary number.
There's no real part to this.
So we could call this-- the
real part here is just 0.
So this is 0 plus 7i.